finally exit to you he's Parliament's  approval mep say transitional  arrangements after the UK officially  leaves must strictly not exceed three  years in an overhauled car approval  system a fine of thirty thousand euros  per vehicle could be slapped a  manufacturer's court falsifying data in  fast change in time the flexible EU  budget is crucial six billion euros will  be satisfied for growth jobs migration  and security the EU is a big importer of  palm oil but a cultivation damages  ecosystems parliament is calling for the  phasing out of palm oil and biofuels by  2020 up to 500,000 women worldwide were  affected by the breast implant scandal  where bad quality silicone was used mep  sparse stricter regulation on medical  devices  [Music]